make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our beyond Omega level we are
covering an often overlooked but
extremely powerful character the
molecule man Owen Reese now the molecule
man was created by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby and made his debut in Fantastic
Four number 20 in 1963 and he was
introduced as a down-on-his-luck
laboratory technician at a nuclear power
plant and was really depicted as
somewhat of a loser basically but one
day he accidentally turned on a particle
generator exposing himself to a great
deal of radiation and because this
occurred in a comic book
the radiation didn't kill Owen Reese but
instead gave him vast superhuman
abilities specifically the ability to
control energy and matter even on a
subatomic scale now this sort of
incident can really go one of two ways
and faced with the choice of either
using his powers to fight crime or
commit crimes
Owen chose the latter and adopts the
moniker of the molecule man now
initially molecule man did not
comprehend the true level of his power
for instance he believed that he could
only control molecules of an inorganic
nature so anything organic would be
beyond his influence he also thought
that his power came from a metal wand
that he carried which is really pretty
absurd like obviously is this wand
that's giving me powers and not like an
enormous amount of radiation that I was
dealt with but it is a Silver Age coming
but characters were kind of stupid back
then but anyway during a fight with the
Fantastic Four the molecule man ends up
dropping his wand and since he thinks he
has no powers he doesn't try to use him
so he ends up losing because a book is
called the Fantastic Four after all but
following his defeat the molecule man is
imprisoned in an alternate universe by
The Watcher who had realized how big of
a threat he could be if he ever learned
to fully control his abilities now while
molecule man was imprisoned his wand
remained on earth with his consciousness
still lingering within it and allowing
him to use his powers whenever anybody
tried to use it eventually the
consciousness recreated Owen Reese's
body and transferred itself from the
wand to the newly created body his first
goal was to simply destroy the world but
he's ultimately talked out of it get
some counseling and decide that he wants
to be a good person and live a normal
life of course that would be boring so
naturally it doesn't happen molecule man
instead ends up getting transported to
battle world during the first secret
Wars event and is ultimately befriended
by dr. doom who actually helps Owen to
realize the full potential of his powers
so what are the molecule man Owen
Reese's full abilities well
earlier he can manipulate matter on a
subatomic level and as we discussed
earlier originally his powers were
limited to controlling inorganic
material due to the mental blocks he
unwittingly place upon himself as a
result of his lack of confidence now
still he was able to do some impressive
things during this phase in one instance
he disintegrated the Silver Surfer
surfboard Thor's hammer mjolnir aya
man's armor and Captain America's shield
simultaneously it was observed by the
watch of The Watcher who pretty much
knows everything
that molecule man represented a
legitimate threat capable of destroying
entire universes furthermore after
molecule man shoots an energy blast at
the Beyonder he remarks to the blasts
would have been capable enough to
destroy several billion galaxies now
once he learned to control energy during
the Secret Wars event he effectively
became capable of warping reality itself
since basically everything in the
universe is either matter or energy even
when the Beyonder caused extensive
damage to the multiverse molecule man
repaired it in an instant with the wave
of his finger and reconstructed all the
stars in the galaxy instantaneously
after the viondra destroy them now at
the peak of his powers molecule man was
considered the most powerful individual
in the Marvel Universe including such
cosmic level entities as a living
tribunal eternity and death at one point
the only entity thought to be more
powerful than a molecule man was the
Beyonder although he was able to give
two Beyonder a run for his money and a
battle that produced tremors that can be
felt throughout the entirety of the
multiverse during secret Wars to later
both Beyonder and molecule man's power
levels would be reckoned to be at a far
lower level than their peaks with the
total power of both of them being equal
to that of one Cosmic Cube now Owen
remarked that during this period he was
on a lower tier in terms of power than
both the Living Tribunal and eternity
even after this change however he was
able to defeat the Beyonder in the
century on separate occasions now later
during Jonathan Hickman Secret Wars
event which was related in name only to
the previous Secret Wars it was revealed
that Owen Reese was actually created by
an alien race known as the beyonders
which initially wasn't related to the
Beyonder at all from the first seeker
wars but was later retconned so that he
actually belongs to this race of aliens
but regardless the beyonders created a
version of Owen Reese in each universe
to be a bomb capable of destroying it so
whenever a molecule man dies the
universities in will be destroyed
shortly after now a lot of what happens
with molecule man during this event
actually relates to God king doom a
super powerful version of Doctor
powered by the molecule man and we're
gonna cover that guy in a separate video
but after the events of secret Wars when
the multiverse as we know it had been
destroyed
owen basically travels with the
Fantastic Four creating new universes
and is described by Valyria Richards as
being a repository of unlimited power as
well as being omnipotent but yeah
molecule man at his peak was
ridiculously overpowered it was insane
how powerful he was literally like when
the beyond ordering Secret Wars - like
destroyed death and was just like
running through the multiverse or
running through the universe causing all
different kinds of problems but let me
try deal in the cosmic entities showed
up to the Beyonder with their hat in
their hand we're like dude can you
please help us that's how powerful this
guy was even with like the molecule man
and in the Beyonder being as powerful as
they were maybe the one above all was
more powerful than them but depending on
who you talk to some will say they were
equally as powerful but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain to make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]